Is it something that
you want to direct as well?
I've gone back and forth on whether
I absolutely had to direct it or not.
Let's just say you're the director.
Let's just not let's not hand over
the reins just yet.
All right, here we go.
I'm Destin Daniel Cretton, and I'm here
chatting with Daniel Hanna.
Hi Daniel.
Hi I’m R.J. Daniel Hanna.
I go by Daniel and
I'm a 2021 Nicholl Fellow.
We're talking about all
things writing and namely
His Nicholl winning script
Shelter Animal,
which I loved so much.
It’s about a female prison inmate
who begins working in animal
shelter in order to gain parole.
Destin Daniel Cretton is
a filmmaker I really respect
and kind of inspired me
to enter the competition.
Welcome, Daniel.
How are you doing?
I really loved your script,
by the way.
I really loved it.
Those characters,
just like, came alive.
I fell in love with them.
I've always found that
tragedy or difficult
dramatic moments are often
kind of the best
time to interject humor
when things get really dark.
It's typically when
the jokes start to fly.
What's kind of like the stages of grief
after you get those notes?
The grief is probably when you feel like
you have something that's really working
and it's not translating.
I have never written something in solitude
and found it to be ready to go and shoot.
I need the reflection
of other people's opinions
to show me what's working and what's not.
This script I worked on for a long time
and I did a short film and rewrote it
after working with actors,
and that process really made me realize
how much extra stuff was in there
in the feature that I didn't need
and what the real heart of the story was.
I have that tendency to
when I'm starting to write a feature,
I just think like, how the hell am I going
to fill 90 to 120 pages?
And then I just start putting more and
more characters and ideas and locations.
For me, almost always,
the rewrite process is about simplifying,
simplifying, simplifying.
Something that I forget again
every single time
I start a new project.
Yeah, I think in every single movie
that I've done, there is a scene
that was one of my favorite scenes
of the movie on the editing floor.
The most fun scene to shoot
the actors were on their A-game.
Everything seemed to be working
about the scene, except that
it wasn't necessary in the movie
and it wasn't working in the movie.
I've often found that
it was a necessary scene to shoot
for the actors to experience
for all of us to experience.
You know, you started in
the indie space,
and obviously working on
a bigger canvas now.
What's it like, as an artist,
navigating that?
From a process standpoint,
I don't see a huge difference
between short term twelve and Marvel.
Obviously, there's bigger toys,
there's more people,
but you're still sitting on a set
looking at a monitor
and you're seeing one shot
that you're trying to get right
and then you move
to the next one.
I said no to a lot of things
that some people would have
said, “You're crazy”
at the time that I said no to them.
I find that for me, being
completely myself in a pitch
and not trying to sell myself,
not trying to do what I think the
other people other want
may not land me the job
every time, but it does
weed out whether or not
I should be doing this
with these people anyway.
And when I look back
at those no's, they defined me
just as much as the things
that I said yes to.
Is that something
that you want to direct as well?
It is. You know, I've
gone back and forth
on whether I absolutely had
to direct it or not.
Let's just say you're the director.
Let's just not. Let's not hand over
the reins just yet.
A little premature.
Congratulations on a
really beautiful script.
I enjoyed it in so many ways.
Thanks so much, and thanks for reading
and taking the time.
I really appreciate it.
All right Daniel. Talk soon.
Talk soon.